Ragazze,parliamoci chiaramente
Nell'arco della nostra vita ognuno di noi ha a che fare con determinati outfit
Chiunque di voi
Qui, in questo video faremo la classifica degli outfit di moda
al numero 1 c'è il vestito che accomuna tutte noi, quel vestito
che compriamo sapendo che lo metteremo solo quando dimagriremo
La domanda è......Ma quando c***o dimagriamo poi
al secondo posto c'è lui il jolly
top adoro! il vestito che quando sei li che cristoni contro l'armadio e non sai che cazzo metterti
ti salva la vita
lo abbiamo anche in altre forme e dimensioni e colori tipo questo
tipo questo....viva il tubino nero!
Questo invece è il per me è NOOOOOO
zia mi conosci da 25 anni
ma secondo te mi metto una cosa del genere?
per fare cosa, per andare alla cresima? ah sai cosa c'è poi?
il tanto non mi vede nessuno
allora praticamente quando vai a fare la spesa
che noi ci mettiamo tipo vestite oscene perché tanto pensiamo di non incontrare nessuno
no va beh dai
e poi incontriamo tutti gli ex uno dopo l'altro
Enzo Miccio e i giudici di Italia's Got Talent....c'è vabbè....OH MIO DIOOO
al quinto posto abbiamo lui:
ADORO
l'outfit da matrimonio
di solito va da un verdino vomitino di bambino ad un giallino cacca di passerotto
sono quei vestiti che paghi un occhio della testa
E quando li metti?una volta sola
Molto bene
e aspettando il prossimo matrimonio ,che non arriverà mai, lo tieni incelofanato nell'armadio
non fate le fighe che voi in casa non state vestite così
allora:ognuno di noi ha il tutozzo antisesso
corrispondente di calzarotto,tutozzo e pile
(canticchia)
Fa parte dell'outfit anche lei....
....la pinza antisesso rosa
Allora poi c'è il completino sexy, tu indossi quando esci con lui, perchè non si sa mai
E poi cosa succede, che vieni a casa e non ci è cambiato nulla
e ci combinerai qualcosa sicuramente il giorno in cui avrai loro
le mutandine di Bridget Jones
dette anche mutande da mestruazione
ADORO!!
lo lascio in camera appeso
col cartellino. Intatto